[Music]
foreign
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month today we're talking about
1979 a year when disco peaked the 80s
lurked and McDonald's introduced the
Happy Meal it was a good year for house
cleaning because both the Dust Buster
and Sony Walkman were introduced to the
world but it was an even better year for
entertainment the ESPN and Nickelodeon
networks both launched and shows like
Three's Company mash and Dallas
dominated the ratings but some good old
boys who are never mean to no harm were
just revving up their Engine movies were
boldly going where men had gone before
just bigger and brighter this time with
an alien a boxer a jerk and some Muppets
along for the ride too so pause the tape
on your Walkman and stop dust busting
between those couch cushions cause it's
time for your year in review 1979 9
Edition
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
on January 26th like a 69 charger off a
perfectly shaped dirt Mound was the
Dukes of Hazard a series that would go
on to air for 147 episodes over seven
seasons it centers around cousins Beau
and Luke Duke who are on probation in
rural Georgia for running moonshine
along with friends and other family
members like cousin Daisy Duke and Uncle
Jesse they spend most of their time
evading corrupt Law Officers Boss Hogg
and Sheriff Roscoe P Coltrane the right
primary sure
thank you
hang on cousin
perhaps the biggest star of the show was
the Duke boys car a customized 1969
Dodge Charger nicknamed the General Lee
and with doors that didn't open it made
every kid of the era wished they were
allowed to enter Mom and Dad's car
through the window and the theme song
sung by country star Waylon Jennings who
was also the series narrator is about as
iconic as theme songs can get it's
definitely worth a listen or a real
listen after this show is over of course
[Music]
no matter what he says nobody lip off
nobody get hot
I'm gonna see what I can do when did you
turn into a [__] Diplomat yeah you
ain't exactly the state department type
Fox you come with me arriving in
theaters on February 9 1979 was the
Warriors about a Turf battle that rages
between fictitious New York City street
gangs from the Bronx all the way to
Coney Island production and later the
film's release was marred with vandalism
and violence given that real gangs in
the area were upset that they weren't
involved and then after the release
rival gangs all started showing up to
the same theaters to watch it so yeah
you get it
sixty thousand soldiers
now there ain't but twenty thousand
police in the whole town can you dig it
can you dig it
but despite that and an initial negative
reception this now certified fresh film
has grown into a cult classic spawning
things like video games and a comic book
series critics say as violent as it is
stylish the Warriors is a thrilling
piece of Pulp filmmaking
picking up Rising missiles now
they're just clearing the planet's
atmosphere and entering the ionosphere
computron readout shows them to be armed
devices of some nuclear type
we've got to destroy them Commander
they're going to blow each other up
Battlestations
standing by maximum laser power standby
laser power standing by heading now to
April 29 1979 and the finale of the
original Battle Star Galactica this
series followed the crew of the only
surviving Battleship after an attack by
a robotic alien race as they hurry to
find a new home on a legendary but
unknown planet known as Earth the series
was canceled after just 24 episodes but
at that point the fan base was there a
write-in campaign revived the eventual
franchise the following year with
Galactica 1980 which ran for 10 episodes
no flashing red dot
activate
blazing
no so don't fire it's there
how do you know
they're waggling
waggling Battlestar Galactica was later
remade in the early 2000s first as a
reimagined mini-series and later as a
weekly series Paving the way for more
spin-off series and made for TV movies
plus the usual books games comic books
and more that go with a full-on Sci-Fi
franchise critics say bearing an
unflattering resemblance to another
Space Opera set in a galaxy far far away
Battlestar Galactica offers little more
than cutting-edge visual effects
[Music]
I was on
also ending its run in 1979 was the cop
drama series Starsky and Hutch with the
final airing on May 15th after four
seasons and 93 episodes in total this
series follows two detectives Starsky
and Hutch as they solve crimes with the
help of an informant named Huggy Bear
while hanging around the fictional town
of Bay City California you sure you want
to do that
yes I'm sure
you sure you don't want me to take just
one little peek underneath that hood
if you don't get in this car right now
after all the things I've said I'm gonna
leave alone that's what I'm afraid of
straight up and in about a million
pieces
Starsky and Hutch also features yet
another iconic TV vehicle with its red
and white Ford Gran Torino originally
intended to be a green and white camaro
before Ford stepped in and of course the
car has lived on in the 2004 money
making remake film starring Ben Stiller
and Owen Wilson
um
Paul Jinx nothing last time I took the
fight too lightly and this man was just
plain lucky but this time this time you
all will see the real Apollo Creed The
Whole World's Gonna See the real Apollo
Creed lightning fast and hard to catch
no plan no driving just business
Rocky do you think you have a chance
this time against Apollo
but although it looks pretty mad
entering the ring on June 15th in 1979
was the boxing film Rocky II with
Sylvester Stallone reprising his titular
role from the 1976 sleeper hit Rocky
this time around Rocky Balboa struggling
to adjust to family life is lured into a
rematch demanded by Apollo Creed whom
Rocky nearly beat in the first film
Rocky II which began the trend of
Stallone also directing the Rocky movies
to go along with writing them was
another big hit for the now franchise as
it became the third highest grossing
film of the year in the U.S
nothing
make sure the greatest night in the
history of my life
I just want to say one thing
to my wife's home
[Music]
numerous sequels followed eventually
evolving into a couple of spin-off films
based on Apollo Creed's son all part of
a franchise that has become a total box
office knockout Adrian critics say Rocky
2 is a movie that dares you to root
again for the ultimate Underdog and
succeeds due to an infectiously powerful
climax
oh my God
also making contact in June of 79 was
the sci-fi horror flick alien about the
crew of a commercial Starship who are
stalked by a deadly life form that has
joined them for a ride the film was
directed by Ridley Scott and Mark
Sigourney Weaver's first lead role Scott
said that the role of Ripley came down
to Weaver and Meryl Streep with Weaver
ultimately winning the job
oh
[Music]
alien was a commercial success and
launched a media franchise that includes
novels comic books video games toys and
more films like sequels prequels and
even a crossover with The Predator
franchise plus the very certified fresh
film which won an Oscar for best visual
effects has cemented a legacy as one of
the best science fiction horror films of
all time even being selected for
preservation in the United States film
registry critics say a modern classic
alien blend science fiction horror and
Bleak poetry into a seamless hole
[Music]
I'm Waldorf we're here to Heckle a
Muppet movie settlement that's straight
ahead private screening room D private
screening yeah they're afraid to show it
in public oh
look at this place what a dump heading
theaters on June 22nd of 1979 was the
Muppet movie the first theatrical film
in Jim Henson's Muppets franchise this
musical comedy tells the origin story of
The Muppets with Kermit the Frog setting
out on a cross-country journey to Los
Angeles in search of success in Show
Business and picking up other
like-minded Muppets along the way where
are you going where we're following our
Dream really I have a dream too
but you'll think it's stupid no no tell
us tell us well I want to go to Bombay
India and become a movie star you don't
go to Bombay to become a movie star you
go where we're going Hollywood sure if
you want to do it the easy way
picked up a weirdo the movie produced by
Henson featured several cameos from
stars like Steve Martin Mel Brooks and
Orson Welles and to go along with its
certified fresh status The Muppet Movie
picked up two Oscars for the score and
the song Rainbow Connection and led to
several movies and series across various
media featuring The Muppets my favorite
is the Muppet Babies critics say the
Muppet movie the big screen debut of Jim
Henson's plush Creations is smart
lighthearted and fun for all ages
over there
you missed Mr Bond
as you said
such good sport
stirring not shaking things up on June
29 1979 was the 11th film in the James
Bond series Moonraker and the fourth to
Star Roger Moore as the popular MI6
agent this time around James Bond makes
his way into outer space while
investigating the hijacking of an
American space shuttle and eventually
finds himself in a fight to save all of
mankind inspired by a boosted interest
in the Sci-Fi genre at the time mostly
thanks to Star Wars this film ended up
with a budget twice the size of the Bond
film before it
it's entering the Earth's atmosphere
James is so last chance
[Music]
foreign
but that paired with a poor reception
from critics it ranks 20th out of 27 on
our list of Bond films ranked by Tomato
Meter didn't stop it from making a huge
payday at the box office becoming the
highest grossing film in the franchise
up until 1995's GoldenEye critics say
featuring one of the series's most
ludicrous plots but outfitted with Primo
gadgets and spectacular sets Moonraker
is both silly and entertaining
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
scaring its way into theaters on July 27
in 1979 was the Amityville Horror based
on the 1977 book of the same name and
the first film about the modern folk
tale that allegedly took place in
Amityville New York in 1974. the film
follows a young couple played by James
Brolin and Margot Kidder who are
terrorized by Supernatural forces after
buying a new home that was the scene of
a recent Mass killing it kind of seems
like they were asking for it
I know
it
is the passage
12.
[Music]
The Amityville Horror wasn't a huge hit
with critics although many in the horror
circles place it in high regard but it
was a box office success becoming one of
the highest grossing Independent films
ever at the time a remake came out in
2005 with names like Ryan Reynolds and
Chloe Grace Moretz involved and earned
similar critical in box office results
leaving the original film as the one
with the lasting Legacy critics say dull
and disappointing the best that can be
said for the Amityville Horror is that
it set a low bar for its many sequels
and remakes
[Music]
foreign
things really started to heat up in
August of 79 with the release of the
psychological War drama Apocalypse Now
which was directed produced and
co-written by Francis Ford Coppola the
film features the likes of Marlon Brando
Robert Duvall Martin Sheen Lawrence
Fishburne Harrison Ford and Dennis
Hopper it follows a captain played by
sheen on a secret mission to assassinate
a special forces Colonel played by
Brando who has been deemed to be insane
after a grueling year of filming and an
extended editing process Apocalypse Now
finally open to rave reviews and Big
Time box office success not to mention
earning eight Oscar Noms including best
picture and picking up two wins for best
cinematography and best sound
wow
today it's widely considered to be one
of the greatest and most influential
films ever made with one of the more
memorable lines ever spoken in a movie
it was courtesy of Robert Duvall's
character when he said I love the smell
of napalm in the morning critics say
Francis Ford Coppola's haunting and
hallucinatory Vietnam War epic is cinema
at its most audacious and visionary
laughs
science officer Spock
reporting as ordered captain
please sit down
Spock you haven't changed a bit
you're just as warm and sociable as ever
no have you doctor
as your continued bread election for
irrelevancy demonstrates as 1979 entered
its final frontier AKA December Star
Trek the motion picture blasted off into
theaters 10 years after the series on
which it was based went off the air for
the first installment in the film series
Captain Kirk who's now an admiral
working at a desk is tasked with
stopping an ominous alien Cloud that's
heading toward Earth which he does by
getting the band back together on the
Enterprise after Studio execs were never
really that happy with Star Trek the
series during its initial run it took
success in syndication to finally get
the ball rolling on a film around 1975.
at one point it turned into another
series called Star Trek phase 2 before
shifting Focus back to a motion picture
[Music]
or Clemson
Mr Decker emergency
alert Wormhole get us back an Impulse
power forward
the results Star Trek the motion picture
wasn't a huge hit with critics or fans
really but it made just enough money
after a ballooning budget to justify a
sequel and thankfully because now
there's a whole bunch of really good
ones critics say featuring a patchwork
script and a dialogue heavy storyline
whose biggest villain is a cloud Star
Trek the motion picture is a less than
auspicious debut for the franchise dear
Harry
guess what I'm rich beyond my wildest
dreams but I haven't forgotten our deal
is that postcard I promised you I bet
you thought you'd never get it huh your
friend forever
how do you like that
promise me a post country sent me a
postcard
kid has integrity and finally ending the
year on a low note but in a good way was
the certified fresh Steve Martin comedy
The Jerk his first starring role in a
feature film in it Martin plays a naive
kid from the country who decides to
leave his sheltered life and experience
the ways of the big city a place where
his simple-mindedness helps him but also
hurts him co-written by Martin and
directed by Carl Reiner this marked the
first of four comedies the pair would
make together over a five-year span
including the Man with Two Brains I
don't need anything
except this
the last day and that's the only thing I
need is this
I don't even visit this this ashtray
this paddle day
[Music]
the essay of alligator that's all I need
the film also starred Bernadette Peters
as Marie a role that Martin wrote
specifically for her especially
considering that they were in the middle
of a four-year relationship at the time
of filming critics say crude crass and
oh so quotable the jerk is nothing short
of an all-out comedic showcase for Steve
Martin there it is 1979. I don't know
about you but I'm inspired to go turn my
car into a potential Hollywood star we
can just revisit some of these great
shows and movies for inspiration we hope
you enjoyed this little trip back in
time and speaking of time I'll see you
next
time